engaging with your customer isn't always
as easy as it may seem some companies
have gotten themselves into some pretty
sticky situations because of the lack of
thought they put into responding to
customer feedback one example is when
Lululemon a popular yoga clothes company
blame their customers for the flaw and
their yoga pants the response was not
consistent with the tone or the voice
the company typically displays to their
customers when you're responding your
goal should be to attempt to make things
right for your customer or sincerely
offer whatever support you can you're
going to want to keep track of
complaints suggestions or feedback and
use those opinions as options to improve
your product now when you want to
respond to customers keep in mind the
following things don't wait too long to
respond but make sure you're not being
overly reactive when you can try to
avoid templated responses well it may be
easier for your team to just send them
out you want to show each customer that
you appreciate the feedback because
after all they're only trying to help
you improve your product and because of
this you should thank the user for their
feedback and if there's a problem take
ownership over that problem it is your
product after all if it's something the
customer could do to improve the problem
try something like hey your feedback was
helpful or sorry you're having trouble
with that no viewing the settings we may
not have been clear enough as where you
can find that so try clicking in the
lower left hand corner to see your
settings if it doesn't work go ahead and
reach out to support at abarca medcom
and we'll try to fix it right away and
finally like I said before monitor the
situation make sure you're tracking all
the feedback and you want to make sure
whatever problem customers are having
end up being solved make sure you're
listening to the feedback and getting
the full story of what's going on if
somebody gives you feedback like I like
that you offer a vet service for my dog
but it could be better this is really
vague and doesn't really help you build
off of so we at a bark mint should
attempt to reach out and get a better
understanding of how we can improve
their customer experience which could
help us in the long run and make more
customers happy